ان غادرت هذه الغربان هذا البرج التاريخي
سقط الملك وسقطت معه بريطانيا الى الابد
سته غربان على الاقل يجب الا تفارق برج
لندن التابعه للقصر الملكي فما قصتها وما
علاقتها بالعرش الملكي في بريطانيا
هنا لندن وهذا الرجل يدعى وهو برتبه عقيد
في الحرس الملكي البريطاني لديه وظيفه
واحده فقط وهي رعايه هذه الغربان وحراستها
التي تعيش في برج العاصمه التاريخي الشهير
الاسطوره تقول ان المملكه البريطانيه
ستنهار ما لم يتم الاحتفاظ بسته غربان على
الاقل داخل برج لندن في الاوقات كافه
وهناك عده روايات تفسر تلك الاسطوره
الغريبه قبل اكثر من 300 عام حدث حريق
لندن الكبير ما ادى الى نقص في المواد
الغذائيه وقتها لجا الكثير من سكان لندن
الى اصطياد واكل شتى انواع الحيوانات
والطيور وكانت الغربان منها
هنا تدخل احد المستشارين وقيل انه كان من
الكهنه او السحره همس في اذن الملك تشارلز
الثاني قائلا جلاله الملك ان قتل الغربان
نذير شؤم وقد يسقط عرشه
وبسبب ذلك يعتقد ان الملك تشارلز الثاني
كان اول من امر رسميا بضروره الاحتفاظ
بطيور الغربان في ذلك الحصن في الاوقات
كافه
لدينا هنا سته غربان بموجب مرسوم الملكي
واذا غادرت الغربان برج لندن فسوف ينهار
ويتحول لركام وسيصيب المملكه ضرر كبير
حاليا نمتلك ثمانيه غرباء ومن مهام وظيفه
التاكد من انها تتمتع بصحه جيده ويتم
الاعتناء بها
الروايه الاخرى تقول ان هذا البرج الاخضر
في لندن امتلك شهره ماساويه حيث كانت تنفذ
فيه بعض احكام الاعدام تجاه الاعداء
الغربان وقتها كانت حاضره من اجل اطفاء
نوع من الرهبه اثناء تنفيذ هذه الاعدامات
ليكون البرج ايقونه ترغب الخصوم
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه وفي عام
اقتربت الاسطوره من التحقق حينما كادت
غارات الطائره الالمانيه على لندن ان تقتل
اخر غراب متبق حيث حاولت استهدافه بشكل
غير رسمي بهدف اضعاف الروح المعنويه
لبريطانيا حينها امر رئيس الوزراء انذاك
بزياده عددها الى سته غربان على الاقل
والحفاظ على هذا العدد تحت جميع الظروف
مع تكثيف القصف الالماني والخوف الحقيقي
من غزو كان يلوح في الافق وقتها تمسك
الناس بالامل اينما وجدوه وطالما ان
الغربانه كانت لا تزال تعيش في البرج فان
بريطانيا لا يمكن ان تسقط ابدا تم تعيين
اول راع لهذه الغربان عام 1950 تحت مسمى
ريفين ماستر
وكريسسكايف هو سادس شخص يحمل هذا اللقب
وهو الوحيد الذي يمكنه الاقتراب من تلك
الغربان بالاضافه الى سته مساعدين اخرين
يتفقدونها كل دقيقه تحسبا لمرض او ربما
لموت احدها ولزياده الحيطه يتم قص اجنحتها
لضمان بقائها ففرارها وهروبها قد يعرض
بريطانيا لخطر السقوط كما تقول اسطورتهم
وبالطبع لا احد هناك يريد ان تتحقق تلك
الاسطوره